si vous l'avez salon oublier un petit
peu la comédienne attend son prochain
rôle c'est à dire oublier très peu pour
passer à la femme
vous avez été très gentils vous avez
permis de venir dans votre appartement
voir comment vous viviez et nous allons
voir quelle réflexion si vous voulez
tout ça vous à skis protection ça vous a
donné votre reportage de jacques gérard
cornu le voici alice sapritch chez elle
et ce après c'est ce que vous êtes
souvent chez vous comme ça dans votre
appartement dans notre position dans ce
bon fauteuil fume-cigarette herman dams
souvent ce m'arrive assez souvent et
j'aime beaucoup parce que c'est
c'est ici que j'aime je travaille je
rêvasse je pense à des tas de choses
est ce que c'est une chose importante
pouvant l'importance que vous avez conçu
d'une façon particulière non je n'ai pas
conçus d'une façon particulière pour moi
un appartement c'est un endroit où je
dois être bien vous voyez c'est un
appartement agréable qui est simple je
pense qu'ils me convient je suis entouré
d'un libre de mes boules que j'aime sont
des boules que j'achète au cours de mes
voyages
quand je tourne 9 c'est la première
chose que je fais c'est slash est une
boule chaque fois voyez celle là ça
vient d'argenton-sur-creuse je viens de
tourner un film et c'est l'appartement
que vous le fassiez on vous conseille ce
que par exemple vous allez chercher ce
coup une chineuse comme nombreux pas du
tout il ne fait je pense qu'il est
confortable
il me convient mais au fond voile et
patrice le fond de mon caractère je suis
in many shell est l'endroit où je suis à
présent pour moi le confort donc je
pense que ce n'est pas laid mais au fond
je porte en moi un côté nomade ma maison
c'est c'est moi même je suis très bien
ici mais je peux très bien ailleurs
aussi ce fameux fume-cigarette d'alice
sapritch
une raison d'être véritable star au
comportement non pas du tout c'est vrai
que je fume beaucoup hélas de plus en
plus et mon fume cigarette c'est quand
même un objet qui qu'ils arrêtent la
nicotine puisque j'ai un filtre je fume
des cigarettes afic et j'arrive à
l'intérieur et au fond c'est devenu
maintenant une habitude et c'est presque
un éventail vos livres à un yacht et
qu'ils consultent leurs commandes
les livres aussi je suis une lectrice un
peu particulière je veux dormir dans les
nir entourent aide à l'irs et ce n'est
pas pour autant que je lis toute la
journée
mais je sais qu'ils sont à ma
disposition et jeudi d'une façon à
bâtons rompus btan
si vous gravissez encore quelques
échelons disons non à la popularité box
office y est ce que vous chantez
l'appartement
je ne crois pas comme je voulais dit
toute possession est une servitude et je
veux être libre
non je ne je ne pense pas même si
j'étais une star de cinéma même si je
gagne beaucoup d'argent même si vous
voyez je suis superstitieuse parce que
rien ne me dit que je veillerai tant
d'argent
je garderai toujours cet appartement qui
me plaît beaucoup
le téléphone sonne parce que il est il
est à mon image
j'aime être à la campagne à paris j'ai
un jardin
je profite du jardin de mes voisins il
est à la fois dans le centre de paris et
isolées au fond il me convient
il lui d'être bien pour moi je n'aime
pas la parra ne sais pas c'est pas du
tout dans mes goûts
hier soir j'avais un ami j'aime beaucoup
qui est très riche qui aime qui a le
goût de la parra il voyage avec tout son
argent trier des malles entières
je dois dire qu'il en a les moyens il
m'amuse et beaucoup mangent toujours oui
oui d'accord 4,7 à traficoter sa part
dimanche soir oui je qualifie jeanne
typique je vais parler de lui aussi
c'est gérard oury qui m'a fait une star
pourquoi vous avez beaucoup c'est pas
parce que je suis une star qu'on
m'appelle quand je n'étais pas star ou
au fait je suis pas je pense pas que
c'est à cause de ça c'est parce que où
ce sont des amis ou ses pourra faire
quand vous êtes chez vous comme
aujourd'hui ce qu'il ya un rituel dans
le déroulement de votre journée se passe
comment d'abord je me déshabille tout de
suite je rentre chez moi c'est à dire
que je mets un peignoir très confortable
je prends un bain et je me mets en
peignoir c'est très exceptionnel que je
vous reçois en europe
je croyais dû peut-être pour recevoir en
peignoir j'ai des espaces non pas du
tout mais enfin je trouve que c'est un
peu
un peu trop familier de recevoir en fait
l'histoire je me mets donc en peignoir
et je suis rarement à 6 je m'installe
très confortablement allongé sur un
divan
je lis et c'est tard un plaisir pour moi
d'être entouré de livres de cigarettes
de mon poste de radio et de mon
téléphone sur nos blocs portes de la
garde-robe de dice a priori trouve au
genre de tenue des choses très
confortable très simple encore une fois
rédactrice chez vous ça ça correspond à
ce que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
professionnellement je suis
naturellement obligé d'avoir ce qu'on
appelle une garde robe comédienne chez
skyrock je lai évidemment j'ai des robes
du soir j'ai détenu un peu plus
sophistiquée bon mais tout ça comme les
bijoux tout ce qui est extérieur à
l'être humain m'intéresse à dose
homéopathique je ne suis pas ce qu'on
appelle une femme coquette
je n'ai jamais je n'ai jamais travaillé
dans la vie pour plaire écoutez bien ce
que je vais vous dire c'est très
important pour plaire d'une façon
artificielle à l'homme à l'homme navale
être humain en face de moi il faut que
les gens axe m'accepte tels que je suis
avec mes défauts mes défauts sur mon
visage avec ce que je suis mais
l'artifice ne m'intéresse pas tellement
ce que vous avez besoin de vous vous
regardez vivent dans une classe à new
york ce genre de ça et croyez moi les
moments les plus pénibles de ma journée
c'est quand on me maquille j'ai fini par
en prendre l'habitude mais
je déteste aller chez le coiffeur à
cause de ça parce qu'être devant une
glace avec des bigoudis sous des casques
et se regarder dans une glace
sam est très pénible vous apprenez vos
rôles dans cette chambre et sur ce livre
oui tous mes personnages sortent de
cette petite part se dit bien ils
sortent de cette petite pas car en
principe ce travail que je fais dans
cette chan et le travail le plus
important quand je suis sur le plateau
on travail consiste simplement à prendre
les places que le metteur en scène me
donne et à me donner quelques
indications définitive mais en principe
on travaille se fait d'abord seul ici
j'apprends le rôle et ensuite le
personnage commence à bouger
j'appelle bouger il quitte la position
horizontale pour pour être verticale et
pour marcher je vois le personnage
marché c'est très important pour moi
parce que c'est dans la démarche que je
trouve le mouvement intérieur du
personnage
à ce moment là quand le personnage est
bien en moi le dernier travail consiste
à avoir mon metteur en scène en face de
moi comme vous l'êtes
à ce moment là je lui dis voilà pierre
rajon si dans ces cas là on se dit c'est
ça passe comme ça pierre cardinal est
mon ami jean louis borie mon équipe
comme on dit ils viennent là vous voyez
que j'ai une façon particulière de
travailler et à ce moment là je leur dis
voilà voilà comment je conçois le
personnage est ce que vous êtes d'accord
à ce moment-là bord il m'a dit oui mais
dense
dans ce passage je voudrais un peu plus
aussi un peu moins cela il parle et je
recommence un autre travail qui est le
travail définitive dans ma tête à ce
moment là laurent les prêts il est
habillé il marche et je vous le propose
donc c'est sûr sony connaissent tous les
personnages dans les sols absolument
absolument savoureux accordons beaucoup
de parfums aussi attirés par les iphone
tout à l'heure je vous ai dit que je
n'étais pas collectionneur mais c'est
une petite manie quand même j'adore les
parties et tous les parfums parce que je
ne mets jamais un seul parfum jeu mais
plusieurs parfums j'arrange amata sont
en profond paris
quand vous êtes comme ça et dans les
soviétiques vous regardez pas la fenêtre
quel est votre pensée la plus fréquente
regardez leur disant que peut-il vous
répondent d'abord vous voyez ce que je
bois
ces arbres pour le moment il n'y a pas
de feuille et je vous que je suis bien
quelle est la propriété à la campagne
qui me donnerait cette joie d'être au
centre de paris au coeur de paris et
d'être à la campagne ça c'est une chance
que j'apprécie je déteste les propriétés
je n'en ai pas je ne crois pas que j'en
aurai mais par contre être dans le
centre de paris à deux pas de mes amis
de mes bistrot que j'aime vous les
connaissez être là avec mon téléphone
être à trois minutes du centre de tout
ce qui se passe dans le monde entier et
quand je dis le monde entier
c'est-à-dire au coeur de paris ça ça
nous plaît beaucoup c'est un luxe et mon
seul luxe parce que vous êtes saturation
générale opposant sans doute une femme
soldat corbeil sais c'est pas tout à
fait exact
je ne suis pas tout à fait seul dans la
vie puisque vous voyez ce tableau ce
tableau à une histoire c'est le tableau
de ma petite nièce qui presque ma fille
car je ne vois pas de différence entre
quelqu'un qu'on aime je n'ai pas le sens
de la maternité
c'est une fille que j'aime parce que
elle me plaît tel quel et j'espère
qu'elle me décevra pas elle choisit une
carrière un métier très dur c'est à dire
la peinture mais je n'ai pas le droit de
décourager car hélas si c'est une
passion je veux être l'élément de sa
passion et je veux les délais je vous
avais très peur que les gens voter soit
parce que vous avez peur de décevoir les
gens bien sûr bien sûr c'est même mon
premier souci de ne pas décevoir les
erreurs humaines
on n'y arrive pas toujours mais je m'y
efforce et ceux qui vous aiment pas
monsieur pour le souvenir en facile je
suis quelqu'un de très orgueilleux c'est
qu'il m'aime pas je ne les aime pas ici
dans cet appartement nous avons vu une
comédienne une femme personnage onu qui
vous avez vu alice et j'aimerais que
vous aimiez c'est al islah telle qu'elle
est avec ses grands défauts et ses
petites qualité
quand j'étais ce conservatoire
j'avais un professeur de littérature que
j'aimais beaucoup
il m'aimait beaucoup aussi et vous
pensez bien que j'en abuse et un de mes
défauts j'en avais beaucoup c'était mon
côté indiscipline et surtout sur
l'horaire les cours commencé à 10 heures
j'arrive air très régulièrement vers 11
heures un jour j'arrive à la gare
saint-lazare terreur il était midi moins
le quart
je suis naturellement très anxieuse de
ça je me dis cette fois mappy il faut
trouver une excuse mais un grand coup
frappé un grand coup
une idée germe dans ma tête je me dis
qu'est ce que je peux dire à mon vieux
professeur pour qu'il soit tout à fait
impressionné je remonte la rue de rome
et dans le couloir du conservatoire je
défais mes cheveux un peu mon corsage
aussi j'entre dans la classe une classe
sidéré de me voir si tard parce que
quand même c'était il était 11h45
je vois mon copain des richards ont
démarré qui tous étaient quand même très
silencieux impressionné par ce retard
qui était le sait pas le le dixième le
15e retard je me mets devant le
professeur en accuser et je lui dit un
pied dans la tombe
mais il ne faudrait pas marcher sur
l'autre non
recommencer je lui dit m
je ne peux pas je ne peux pas vous
expliquer cet hymne est arrivé dans le
métro
tous deux résident
j'étais mais quoi quoi qu'est ce qu'est
ce qui était arrivé au camp j'étais
violent tout sidéré apprend sombre il me
dit ma petite chérie
mais comment mais il n'y avait personne
genest m c'est un wagon presque vide et
4 boillon août essayé de m'embrasser
alors je me suis battu et vous pensez
bien que je me suis défendu comme j'ai
pu voilà dans quel état je suis la
classe a beaucoup ri après mais hélas
moi j'ai des remords qui est dans la
tombe et il faudrait pas marcher sur
l'eau
à breach dormir un peu ce soir puisque
même fait ce soir au magic ton et dans
une boîte vous ressemble par les bois
non non non mais c'est exceptionnel
parce qu'on fait là une fête comme une
grande fête parce que vous partez de
paris c'est pas tellement merdique
jean-philippe patthey sûr je viens
justement pour faire un distinguo de au
théâtre y sont approuvés j'imagine que
je m'en vais après demain c'est pas vrai
du tout je pars le 4 janvier je suis
encore en vacances ou 90 le sept jeunes
environ tournée en france avec les tons
débarré et c'est au mois d'avril que je
m'en bats pour l'afrique ou à laval
alors ça il fallait le dire parce que
leur soit qu'une partie chants maï sur
le plan du rayonnement culturel de la
france c'est quand même plus important
que les derniers voyages de la comédie
française
peut-être oui pourquoi vous avez cet air
un peu éméché en me disant absolument
pas dans le salon nombre quoi je pense
d'abord que vous défendez une pièce
importante car on sait la place qu'un
clochard dans mon jardin tient dans la
version française c'est amusant d'autre
part vous êtes vous même un personnage
culturel même sans texte
tournez-vous un peu parce que vous avez
déjà nonchalamment pas vous imitez mi
temps et c'est alors est ce que vous
savez de quel oeil le public de couleur
vous vois déjà
est-ce qu'il vous connaissent que vous
êtes connu au congo en tout cas je ne
sais pas si le public de couleur me
connais mais en france le public de
couleur même beaucoup alors je ne sais
pas ce que ça va donner là bas mais je
ne connais pas l'afrique
je vous dirai ça à mon retour oui je
sais pas c'est pas important que vous
connaissiez pas l'afrique savoir si
l'afrique connaît sapritch et comment la
phase va vous recevoir
philippe je fais aussi un distinguo vous
évidemment vous avez une façon de rire
avec moi et je savais très bien que ma
carrière est une carrière double g le
côté dramatique la télévision je ne suis
pas si vous avez vous devez dormir le
soir
dorton dormait mais enfin je viens de
tourner un film avec mitrani là une
serveuse qui n'est pas du tout j'ai
passé deux genoux mon nom alors je peux
pas l'avoir vu lui mais en fait il ya
quand même quand il avait dix émissions
à la télévision qu'on n'avait pas vu
c'est arrivé soit les normands seront de
shon d'accord il est blanc mais enfin ma
carrière est une carrière demix oui pour
le moment c'est du comics mais l'année
prochaine ça sera autre chose qu'on va
pas parler de matière sociale il faut ce
we à thierry va limiter ils ont ça dans
sport
on commencera la pamela dernières
nouvelles ce soir avec macky plein pour
ce n'est jamais si bien sûr
non mais attention je crois que le vis
de sa prise c'est d'être imité mais par
vous seulement la salle on croit que
dans ses habits de l'immense que les
travaux du mythe thierry we ask
allemande à la même hauteur
oui on est oui oui nous sommes
malheureusement vrai nom mais c'est une
question de talent et de la nonchalance
de s'arranger du talent il est temps
qu'ils peuvent imiter
oui mais je ne veux pas que les sous
fifres de thierry mimi et j'ai remarqué
d'ailleurs que celui qui vous imitait et
qu'il n'était pas le luron vous imiter
le luron en train de vous aider à henin
ça m'agace profondément pas au bout ltd
alors jamais thierry le luron a mérité
davantage le surnom vous lui avez donné
mon nom et scarlett c'est vous appelle
le mégalo ça n'est pas non plus une
grosse variété mégalo movie amour aussi
aussi lassés d'un autre style
oui et toi tu nages
je la ressemblance est frappante alors
une fois pour toute et avait envie de
mettre les choses au point
c'était il ya quelques années il est
allé plus loin depuis là c'était aller
au stade artisanal et ça m'amusait assez
parce que j'allais connu mme thiery
quand il avait 20 ans il ya dix ans de
ça je ne sais pas quel âge il a mais
enfin il ya 20 ans il ya dix ans et la
paix 20 ans peut-être calculs vont alors
là c'était de dans une boîte justement
d'homosexuels ça nous amusait beaucoup
on était entouré d'amis auriez beaucoup
il n'y avait pas que des homosexuels
c'était une boîte très parisienne bon
c'était au stade artisanal et tout ce
qui est vous qui sort un peu de
l'ordinaire ou bon il prenait une api se
mettait sur sa tête bon mais mais mais
il ya toujours le côté mais je les
laissais un peu trop trop de temps à
mettre des serviettes sur la tête et
c'est devenu industriel est alors quand
ça devient dustrit yale il faut il faut
mettre les choses au point je ne suis
plus du tout du tout du tout d'accord et
je le dis publiquement comme ça tout le
monde est au courant
je ne suis pas fâché je n'ai pas fait de
procès mais les derniers temps il a un
peu dépassé la mesure
et quand on dépasse la mesure je dis
halte parce que mon métier je le fais
avec énormément d'ardeur on dit même
avec du courage sur nos pelles pas
tellement parce que le courage pourquoi
c'est un métier que j'ai choisi que
j'aime
bon mais enfin le métier je le fais et
quand je fais ma publicité c'est moi qui
fais la publicité on me paye pour ça je
n'aime pas du tout du tout qu'on se
serve de moi pour pour leur travail pour
leur boulot
or je pourrais je pense que thierry
s'est beaucoup servi de moi nous nous
sommes entendus dernièrement on a fait
un arrangement
parce que je lui ai dit fais attention
si tu continues
ça va dépasser la mesure et moi à ce
moment-là je prendrai
les devants et moi aussi je ne me
mettrais pas car tu as du talent dans
les imitations
mais moi j'ai aussi du talent dans ma
façon de dire je dirais aussi certaines
choses et peut-être que ce n'est pas
bien alors on est sûr vous êtes en
découdre sur la pente du jour joel
shearer ça vous agace ça veut rigoler
pour quelles raisons ça m'agace pourquoi
parce qu'il est facile il est trop
facile de faire de fer sont enfin entre
guillemets talent parce que bon kirill
de lure on a peut-être mais de se servir
du talent des autres pour pour ce faire
sa carrière et son et son fric soit avec
leur avec le talent de sa prise par
exemple bon c'est ce dont il a le plus
abuser mais il n'est pas le seul
il est de bon ton dans les émissions de
balancer une petite une petite blague à
propos d'ali s'apprête à faire rire
s'amusent en moi je ne comprends pas
c'est ça me dépasse
l'ademe rémy en revanche cela
franchement me vexe et je suis
profondément ennuyé pour finalement on
peut dire des choses certainement mais
dire des choses gentiment et non pas des
choses vexatoires finalement et madame
sapritch et offrait là est extrêmement
gentil de ne pas intenter un procès pour
certaines choses mais ça m'a
profondément choqué franchement et la
vigie je le dis publiquement je ne suis
absolument pas complices il le fait
malgré tout mais comme que malgré tout
et malgré moi je tiens à le dire
publiquement que vous connaissez bien
vous vous rencontrer au plus tôt on
avait mis d'accord non il n'ya pas
d'amitié non c'est un copain c'est pas
un ami mais si où je fais un procès où
je dors
on en
on devient des ennemis et ce n'est pas
c'est pas la peine non plus mais je le
dis je le proclame
je ne suis pas d'accord pour la saison
prochaine il va faire le gymnase et il
m'a promis qu'ils ne mettraient pas dans
son numéro
jeudi ce n'était pas vous comprenez
c'est si c'est agaçant quand il me
décrit qu'il a que j'ai la peau
tellement arraché qui dans fait des sacs
du soir il se fait que pour une femme de
mon âge je ne le suis pas arash comme il
dit vous pouvez regarder bon j'ai assez
de rythme pour ça quand il dit que quand
je jouais super dupont il disait elle
est très aimé des souffles des ouvreuses
parce que à l'entracte elles peuvent
aller se reposer des trucs comme ça
qu'elle a qui l'arrangé à sa façon je
dis non non non non c'est alice commons
cc pas d'imitation des gens pour faire
des mobilités puisque nous en sommes à
une mise au point il ya l'autre main de
points que vous désirez faire m'avait
dit tout à l'heure avant l'émission je
suis une actrice très populaire
des gens me téléphone et désire me voir
en dehors de mon métier et ça vous
n'acceptez pas vous ne voulez pas vous
ne voulez colis non mais vous aller vous
allez faire de la peine à beaucoup de
gens non parce que j'ai une phrase qui
n'est pas de moi qui n'ai pas de compte
non plus parce que on croit que c'est de
cocteau c'est pas vrai c'est du poète
reverdit il n'y a pas d'amour il ya des
preuves d'amour
je voudrais que l'appel que le public
fait à mon égard soit aussi un appel à
double sens vous comprenez c'est moi je
ne peux pas disposer de mon temps pour
recevoir des personnes très gentil mais
pour le bavardage ou pour je ne peux pas
disposer de mon temps or la plupart du
temps les gens des gens me disent venez
donc dîner des gens que je ne connais
pas devenez donc dîner où est ce qu'on
peut vous inviter à prendre le thé etc
alors là ça n'est pas la raison du cycle
donc parce que la rançon du succès ce
n'est pas possible parce que je fais un
métier public je voudrais qu'on même
dans ce que je fais vous comprenez bien
que vous même dans votre livre il vous
aime d'année vous disiez avoir fut jean
paul sartre simone de beauvoir vu sa
shaqiri l'avoir rencontré et on est déçu
et vous dites j'ai plus appris à les
regards décalés connaître après tout ce
qu'il pense il l'écrit pour 20 francs à
l'époque
on en sait bien davantage sur les
écrivains et les artistes en perdant son
temps à les connaître
si gentil d'être venus d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui mais c'est grave ce que vous
dites quand même non pourquoi
une fois quoi il vaut mieux connaître se
refuser quand même à son public mais
mais mais mais mon public là qu'est ce
que je fais jamais je parle à mon public
le public est en face de moi y'a 3
millions 4 millions le jeune sergent 4
millions de personnes
je m'adresse à eux pour m'expliquer pour
expliquer qui je suis et mai mais est ce
que est ce bien utile quand on public
sache comment je fais ma salade alors de
réaction madame non
qui est cette nouvelle idole de la
chanson une tragédienne alice sapritch a
enregistré son premier disque qui
s'intitule s'apprête à nu les hommes
sont des poupées
quand je les déshabillent tout
congestionné comme emma de pilleurs
comme je suis comédienne quand on a
porté une chanson je voulais interprété
la chanson mais hélas vous voyez là il y
a une chose terrible des notes beaucoup
de difficultés parce que vous avez pu le
constater il a fallu se prendre des
cours de chant il a fallu sélectionner
les choses en fonction de sa tessiture
vocale et puis il a fallu aussi lui
apprendre à chanter non seulement de
passer sa voix mais dans un studio
alors ça a été très dur
oui
galibert organisé une veillée à aa
ça va ça le plaisir de la chair le désir
de la ferme ont produit leurs jouets
ce disque vous avez plutôt chanter
décodeur
non je n'ai pas chanté que des gaudriole
j'ai chanté les deux c'est à dire des
choses amusantes des choses dramatiques
mais je suis france vous me connaissez
depuis quelques temps je suis ce
personnage à la fois un drôle dramatique
triste désespéré je suis comme la nuit
allongés dans le déshonneur pour vous
deux mois trois années de conservatoire
pour en faire du cochon l'horreur c'est
dans la boîte
non mais
les émaux
je
je le
combien d'heures faut-il pour faire un
disque comme ça celui là plus de sang
c'est à dire à peu près cinq fois plus
que pour les autres artistes qui sont
déjà dans le métier de la chaussée
regardez là vous voyez comme suis entré
ici pour la première fois c'était un
soir où johnny enregistrés et j'ai vu
mon nom à côté de johnny côté de sardou
à côté de sylvie vartan et ça ça
m'impressionne toujours un peu je vais
te fais ma voix je veux je veux parce
que je veux chanter des choses très
dures
je veux chanter des sur des rythmes sûr
surtout ça quand même pas l'air
déclenché at no no no no justement c'est
le contraire que je veux faire je veux
faire des champs de sauvages
car mes frères et moi je